où l'on peut utiliser les capacités et les technologies
dérivées de ces animaux
et des plantes,
pour résoudre ces problèmes.
Regardons deux problèmes environnementaux.
Nous en sommes à l'origine,
c'est l'homme en interaction avec l'environnement
et faisant des choses plutôt contrariantes.
Le premier est dû à la croissance démographique.
Cette croissance démographique mondiale est telle
que l'on oblige l'agriculture à produire de plus en plus.
Et pour faire ça,
les fermiers utilisent plus de produits chimiques.
Ils se servent d'engrais, de nitrates, de pesticides...
tout ce qui peut faciliter l'augmentation des récoltes,
mais il y a des répercussions négatives.
L'une d'elles est que si l'on utilise beaucoup d'engrais sur les terres,
tout ne part pas dans les récoltes.
Une grande quantité reste dans les sols.
Et puis quand il pleut,
ces produits chimiques vont dans la nappe phréatique.
Après la nappe phréatique,
ils vont dans les ruisseaux, dans les lacs, dans les rivières
et dans la mer.
Et si l'on introduit ces produits, ces nitrates,
dans ces genres de milieux,
des organismes de ces milieux en seront affectés,
les algues par exemple.
Les algues adorent les nitrates et les engrais.
Donc elles vont absorber tous ces produits
et si les conditions sont bonnes, elles produiront en masse.
Elles produiront beaucoup de nouvelles algues.
On appelle ça une efflorescence.
Le problème est que, lorsque les algues se reproduisent ainsi,
elles privent l'eau d'oxygène.
Et quand cela arrive,
les autres organismes dans l'eau ne peuvent pas survivre.
Donc, que fait-on ?
On essaye de produire un robot qui mangera toutes ces algues,
qui les consommera et rendra cela sûr.
Cela est le premier problème.
Le deuxième problème est aussi de notre responsabilité :
la pollution par les hydrocarbures.
Le pétrole sort des moteurs que nous utilisons,
comme ceux de nos bateaux.
Parfois, les navires-citernes vident leurs cuves en mer,
le pétrole est ainsi répandu.
Ne serait-il pas sympa si nous pouvions traiter cela,
via des robots qui mangeraient la pollution des nappes de pétrole ?
C'est donc ce que nous faisons.
Nos robots mangent la pollution.
Pour faire ces robots,
nous nous inspirons de deux organismes.
À droite, là, vous voyez le requin pèlerin.
Le requin pèlerin est un énorme requin.
Il est non carnivore, vous pouvez donc nager avec lui,
comme vous pouvez le voir.
Le requin pèlerin ouvre sa bouche,
plonge sous l'eau, afin de récolter du plancton.
Au fur et à mesure, il digère la nourriture,
et ensuite il utilise cette énergie dans son corps pour avancer.
Donc, pourrions-nous faire un tel robot,
comme le requin pèlerin qui traverse l'eau
et mange la pollution ?
Eh bien, regardons si cela est possible.
Mais également, nous nous inspirons d'autres organismes.
J'ai ici une photographie d'une corise
et la corise est vraiment mignonne.
Lorsqu'elle nage dans l'eau,
elle utilise ses pattes en forme de pagaies pour avancer.
Nous avons donc pris ces deux organismes
et nous les avons combinés afin de réaliser un nouveau type de robot.
En fait, parce que nous utilisons la corise comme inspiration,
notre robot rame au-dessus de l'eau, [NdT : row = rame]
nous l'avons donc appelé : le « Row-bot ».
Donc le Row-Bot est un robot qui rame.
OK. À quoi ressemble-t-il ?
Voici des photos du Row-bot,
vous le verrez,
il ne ressemble pas aux robots que nous avons vus au début.
Google se trompe : les robots ne ressemblent pas à ça,
ils ressemblent à ça.
J'ai donc un Row-bot ici.
Je vous le montre,
cela vous donne un sens de l'échelle,
et ils ne ressemble pas du tout aux autres.
OK, il est donc fait de plastique,
et regardons les composants
qui font que le Row-bot
est vraiment spécial.
Le Row-Bot est fait en trois parties,
et ces trois parties sont comme les parties de tout organisme.
Il a un cerveau,
il a un corps
et il a un estomac.
Il a besoin de son estomac pour créer de l'énergie.
Tous les Row-bot auront ces trois composants,
tout organisme les aura,
alors analysons-les l'un après l'autre.
Il a un corps,
et ce corps est fait en plastique,
et il est à la surface de l'eau.
Il y a des palmes sur le côté ici,
des pagaies qui l'aident à bouger,
tout comme la corise.
Il a un corps en plastique,
mais il y a une bouche en caoutchouc souple ici,
et une autre ici ; il a deux bouches.
Pourquoi a-t-il deux bouches ?
L'une pour faire entrer la nourriture,
et l'autre pour la faire sortir.
Donc comme vous pouvez le voir, il a une bouche et un derrière.
ou un --
(Rires)
quelque chose d'où les choses sortent,
qui est tout comme un véritable organisme.
Il commence donc à ressembler au requin pèlerin.
Ça, c'est le corps.
Le deuxième unité pourrait être l'estomac.
Nous avons besoin d'énergie dans le robot et nous devons traiter la pollution,
la pollution va donc là,
et quelque chose doit se produire.
Il y a une pile au milieu ici, une pile à combustible microbienne.
Je vais le poser, et je vais prendre la pile à combustible.
Ici, au lieu d'avoir des piles,
au lieu d'un système d'énergie standard,
il a ceci.
Ceci est un estomac.
C'est vraiment un estomac,
vous pouvez introduire de l'énergie par ce côté sous la forme de pollution,
et cela crée de l'électricité.
Qu'est-ce donc ?
Une pile à combustible microbienne.
C'est comme une pile à combustible,
que vous pourriez avoir à l'école,
ou vu aux informations.
Les piles à combustible prennent de l'hydrogène et de l'oxygène,
les combinent ensemble, et vous avez de l'électricité.
C'est une technologie bien établie, c'était dans les missions Apollo.
Il y a 40, 50 ans de cela.
Ceci est plus récent.
Sa combustion est microbienne.
C'est le même principe :
ça prend l'oxygène d'un côté,
mais au lieu d'avoir de l'hydrogène de l'autre,
il utilise une soupe,
et à l'intérieur de cette soupe, il y a des microbes vivants.
Maintenant, si vous prenez quelques matériaux organiques --
ça pourrait être des déchets, des aliments,
ou une part de votre sandwich --
vous le déposez ici, les microbes mangeront cette nourriture,
et ils la transformeront en électricité.
Pas seulement ça, mais, en sélectionnant le bon type de microbes,
vous pouvez utiliser la pile à combustible microbienne
pour traiter une partie de la pollution.
Si vous choisissez les bons microbes,
les microbes mangeront les algues.
Si vous utilisez d'autres microbes,
ils mangeront l'éther du pétrole et le pétrole brut.
Donc vous pouvez voir comment cet estomac peut être utilisé
pas uniquement pour traiter la pollution
mais également pour générer de l'électricité de cette pollution.
Donc, le robot va se déplacer à travers l'environnement,
prendre de la nourriture dans son estomac,
digérer cette nourriture, créer de l'électricité,
utiliser cette électricité afin de se déplacer,
et continuer à faire cela.
D'accord, alors, voyons ce qui se passe lorsque nous démarrons le Row-bot --
quand il rame.
Ici nous avons plusieurs vidéos,
la première chose que vous verrez, espérons-le,
est la bouche ouverte.
Les bouches avant et arrière s'ouvrent
et lorsqu'elles seront ouvertes,
le robot commencera à avancer.
Il se déplace sur l'eau
de sorte que la nourriture entre et que les déchets sont éliminés.
Dès qu'il a assez bougé,
il s'arrête et il ferme ses bouches --
il les ferme doucement --
il s'immobilisera
et digèrera la nourriture.
Bien sûr, ces piles à combustible microbiennes,
contiennent des microbes.
Vous voulez que de l'énergie
sorte de ces microbes aussi vite que possible.
Mais, nous ne pouvons les forcer,
et ils génèrent qu'un petit quantité d'électricité par seconde.
Ils créent des milli-, ou des microwatts.
Mettons cela en place dans le contexte.
Votre téléphone portable,
l'un de ces modernes,
en l'utilisant, cela prend un watt.
C'est donc mille ou un million de fois autant d'énergie que celle
de la pile à combustible microbienne.
Comment faisons-nous face à cela ?
Eh bien, lorsque le Row-Bot a terminé sa digestion,
quand il a pris la nourriture,
il restera sans bouger et attendra d'avoir consommé toute cette nourriture.
Cela peut prendre plusieurs heures, voire plusieurs jours.
Le cycle typique d'un Row-Bot ressemble à cela :
tu ouvres la bouche,
tu te déplaces,
tu fermes ta bouche,
tu t'arrêtes et tu attends.
Une fois la nourriture digérée,
alors tu peux aller faire la même chose une nouvelle fois.
Mais, cela ressemble à un véritable organisme, n'est-ce pas ?
Cela ressemble à ce que nous faisons.
Samedi soir, nous sortons, ouvrons la bouche,
nous remplissons nos estomacs,
on s'assoit devant la télé, et on digère.
Quand on en a assez, on recommence.
Avec de la chance, via ce cycle,
à la fin de celui-ci, il nous restera assez d'énergie
pour faire autre chose.
Nous pourrions envoyer un message.
Un message qui dirait :
« Voici la quantité de pollution que j'ai mangée »,
ou, « C'est le genre de choses que j'ai rencontrées »,
ou « Voici où je suis ».
L'habilité d'envoyer un message qui dit « Voici où je suis »,
est vraiment, vraiment très important.
Pensez aux marées noires que nous avons déjà eues,
ou aux proliférations d'algues,
on aimerait y mettre un Row-bot,
pour qu'il mange toute cette pollution,
et alors vous devez les récupérer.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que ces Row-bots,
ce Row-Bot que j'ai ici,
il contient des moteurs, des fils,
il contient des composants qui ne sont pas eux-mêmes biodégradables.
Les Row-bots actuels contiennent des batteries toxiques.
On ne peut pas les laisser dans l'environnement,
on doit les suivre,
et quand ils ont fini leur travail,
les récupérer.
Cela limite le nombre de Row-Bots que vous pouvez utiliser.
Si, d'autre part,
vous avez un robot un peu comme un organisme biologique,
quand il arrive à la fin de sa vie,
il meurt et il se dégrade.
Alors, ne serait-il pas super que ces robots,
au lieu d'être comme ça, en plastique,
soient produits en d'autres matériaux,
qui se bio-dégradent entièrement ?
Cela change la façon dont nous utilisons les robots.
Au lieu d'en mettre 10 ou 100 dans l'environnement,
à devoir les suivre,
et lorsqu'ils meurent,
les récupérer,
vous pourriez mettre mille,
un million, un milliard de robots dans l'environnement.
Il suffit de les répandre.
Vous savez que, à la fin de leur vie, ils se dégraderont.
Vous n'avez pas à vous en inquiéter.
Cela change donc ce que vous pensez des robots
et comment vous les utilisez.
La question est : sait-on le faire ?
Et la réponse est oui.
On sait faire des robots qui sont biodégradables.
C'est intéressant, car vous pouvez utiliser des matériaux ménagers
pour faire ces robots biodégradables.
Je vais vous en montrer, vous serez surpris.
Vous pouvez faire un robot en gelée.
Au lieu d'avoir un moteur, comme nous avons en ce moment,
vous pouvez faire des « muscles artificiels ».
Ce sont des matériaux intelligents,
en leur donnant de l'électricité,
et ils se contractent, se courbent, se tordent.
Ils ressemblent à de vrais muscles.
Au lieu d'avoir un moteur, vous avez ces muscles artificiels.
Vous pouvez faire des muscles artificiels avec de la gelée.
En prenant de la gelée, un peu de sel,
et avec un peu de bidouille,
vous pouvez faire un muscle artificiel.
Nous avons montré que vous pouvez créer ces piles microbiennes pour l'estomac
à partir de papier.
Vous pouvez donc fabriquer tout le robot à partir de matériaux biodégradables.
Vous les répandez, et ils se dégradent entièrement.
Eh bien, c'est vraiment très excitant.
Cela va complètement changer la façon dont nous pensons aux robots,
cela vous permet aussi d'être vraiment créatif
si vous pensez à ce que vous pouvez faire avec.
Je vais vous donner un exemple.
Si vous faites un robot en gelée --
vous mangez de la gelée, n'est-ce pas ?
Pourquoi ne pas faire ce type de choses ?
Un robot en oursons gélifiés.
Je l'ai déjà préparé.
Nous y voilà. J'ai un paquet --
j'en ai un saveur citron.
Je vais prendre cet ourson gélifié, Il n'est pas robotique, OK ?
Nous ferons semblant.
Qu'est-ce que vous faites avec ? Vous le mangez --
le citron est sympa.
Essayez de ne pas trop mâcher, c'est un robot, il ne va pas aimer.
et puis, vous l'avalez.
Il va dans votre ventre.
Quand il est dans votre estomac, il bouge, pense, se tord, se penche,
il fait des trucs.
Il pourrait aller plus loin dans vos intestins,
découvrir si vous avez un ulcère ou un cancer,
peut-être faire une injection, ou autre chose.
Vous le savez, une fois qu'il a fait son travail,
il pourrait être digéré par votre estomac,
ou si vous ne le voulez pas,
il pourrait traverser votre corps,
jusqu'aux toilettes,
et se bio-dégrader dans l'environnement.
Cela change donc la manière dont nous pensons aux robots.
Nous avons commencé à regarder les robots qui mangent de la pollution,
puis, nous avons regardé les robots que nous pouvons manger.
J'espère que ça vous donne une idée
de ce que nous pouvons faire avec les futurs robots.
Merci beaucoup pour votre attention.
(Applaudissements)